Once upon a time, a poor soldier was walking along a road when he met the Devil.
"I will make you a rich man," the Devil said.
"But if you die within seven years, I shall take your soul."
"What must I do for the seven years?" The soldier asked.
The Devil was wearing a green coat.
He took it off and he gave it to the soldier.
"There is a pocket in this coat," he said.
The soldier put his hand into the pocket.
"It's full of gold!" He said.
"Yes," the Devil said.
"You can spend as much as you like."
"The pocket will stay full of gold."
"Now, don't forget."
"You must not take off the bearskin."
"You must not take a bath."
"And you must not cut your beard or your hair."
"If you are still alive in seven years' time, I will make you rich."
"If you die before then, I shall take your soul."
With these words, the Devil vanished and the soldier started walking.